do cuttlefish wear their thoughts on
their skin I mean to the extent that
their perception of the of the world
could be described as their thought yeah
that's true they look at you in a way
that other animals don't look at you
they're just so expressive there was a
possibility of using a trick to
indirectly sample the very large number
of neurons by proxy basically a human
has about 200 different ways we can use
our muscles to move with this kit we can
record in an adult cuttlefish probably a
million's cuttlefish and they've sold
the problems their solution is there
there's stuff to be learned just by
understanding them
[Music]
so cuttlefish are our cephalopods and
they actually invented this method of
hiding which involved the hijacking of
part of their musculature into an organ
in their skin to generate controllable
display and the amazing thing about this
controllable display that is controlled
by the nervous system meaning that they
can change the external appearance
extremely fast within a couple of
hundred milliseconds that can completely
change their external appearance
[Music]
you see behind the house of this snail
there's one there's always this little
animal sitting here I should find a name
Johnny also and the bigger one likes to
hide I never threw up here in the corner
the way in which the system is organized
is such that the output of the system is
a set of pixels those are little bags of
pigments they're controlled by a radio
set of muscles and so the diameter of
this pixel is controlled by the rate and
amount of contraction of these muscles
which itself is under the control of up
to 3 million neurons those motor neurons
themselves are located in the brain of
the animal but they're the last layer of
the output of the system so they
represent the output of these complex
computational system that doesn't
matching between an image that the
animal sees and what it produces on its
skin
girls these cameras are zoomed in on
small patches of this animals skin
overlapping so we tile the entire body
in the skin there's thousands of
specialized pigment cells called
chromatophores and each come at affort
receives direct input from motor neurons
projecting from the brain so these
cameras are picking up the expansion and
contraction of these pigment cells and
then use this to infer the activity of
motor neurons and use that to infer the
activity of premotor neurons and sort of
walk deeper into the brain when we
systems neuroscientists try and figure
out what the neural correlates of
perception are we have to design very
complicated experiments behavioral
experiments usually involving learning
of which the results have to be a
relatively simple do you recognize this
or do you not recognize this can you do
simple discrimination tasks in this case
you have a behavioral description of the
output which is complete the animal on
its skin tells you its perception of the
external world
indeed what we're seeing is the output
of the system and we know the input as
well
we control the visual inputs coming in
we have this really high-resolution
behavioral measurement and we want to
infer something about the black box that
is the cuttlefish brain with this
input/output mapping and that's so
that's the big goal here cuttlefish as
cephalopods are doing an operation which
we as humans engineers computer
scientists find extremely difficult to
do what are the features that one needs
to extract so as to reproduce something
that will fool another animal okay in
the attempts that machine vision people
have had to train networks to do that
very simple matching you need hundreds
of thousands of training trials and the
fascinating thing about these animals
that they're born with the ability to
immediately do a camouflage that's
effective which implies that in their
brain they have the solution to this
problem and that if that solution is
encoded in their nervous system and
their genes it must be a relatively
simple solution so that's what we're
getting at or we're trying to get at I
think if we want to learn what is really
fundamental about how brains work in
general we want to compare across the
most different examples as possible our
common ancestor was a small marine worm
that lived about 600 million years ago
that had most likely a very very simple
nervous system so it's all independent
so if we find some common features about
how brains work or how behavior works in
these animals and how it works in
vertebrates like ourselves we can really
say that we can we've learned something
fundamental about how these things work
in general we can't really say that if
we only study one sort of evolutionary
instantiation you want to studied it
because it's so different
not in spite of it
[Music]